escenas de caos en Puerto Príncipe
ciudadanos de la capital haitiana huyen
del enfrentamiento armado entre la
policía y las pandillas que intentan
tomar el control de estas calles con
fronteras invisibles
disparos continuos desde hace una semana
han aterrorizado los residentes de
algunos distritos como 18 y 24 y Chris
obligándolos a abandonar sus casas
Hay que dormir en la calle volví esta
mañana y veo que las cosas siguen igual
lo tengo a donde ir no tengo a dónde ir
según el más reciente informe sobre
Haití en la oficina de las Naciones
Unidas contra la droga y el delito el
creciente tráfico ilegal de armas de
fuego y de drogas agudizan los problemas
de seguridad del país la cifra de
homicidios registrada en 2019 se duplicó
en 2022 llegando a más de 2000 muertes
violentas en un solo año Mientras que el
secuestro modalidad bastante utilizada
por las pandillas aumentó más de 16
veces en 2022 Comparado con 2019 ambos
gráficos demuestran que la situación
humanitaria y la inestabilidad social y
política empeoraron desde el magnicidio
el presidente Joel mois en julio de 2021
otro punto clave preocupa la comunidad
internacional en este informe la
transnacionalización del crimen las
armas que entran Haití provienen en su
mayoría de Estados Unidos y hacen su
tránsito por República Dominicana país
fronterizo zo con Haití el fácil tráfico
de armas se debe a la incompetencia de
las autoridades haitianas en el control
de las fronteras y a la gran cantidad de
importaciones que recibe el país por los
puertos marítimos terrestres y aéreos
debido a la dependencia de ayuda
humanitaria